hey 42 here the room is dark the duvet
is wrapped warm around you you finally
put your damn phone down and you wonder
why am I not asleep yet sometimes no
matter how much you want to you simply
cannot find the off button you tried
everything counting sheep breathing
exercises listening to whales songs
you've even tried counting whales and
listening to sheep songs but nothing is
working why does this happen if mother
nature decided that we needed to spend a
third of the day with charging then why
did she make it so bloody difficult to
do it we all know how frustrating it can
be so let's try to understand what's
preventing you from dozing off and how
you can help it along the little first
things first what is the difference
between being awake and being asleep you
close your eyes you lie still you
breathe deeply
you can even try dribbling a little if
you like but something special has to
happen for you to make the mysterious
switch to the other side there are five
stages of sleep in the first you move
from an alpha state basically
daydreaming into a fetus state where
your brain locks down your muscles and
prepares to move into a deeper sleep you
could say that you are technically
asleep in theta but very likely it's at
this stage where the hypnic jerk can
occur that moment when you suddenly
twitch away as if you're falling we
think it's likely to be caused by your
brain still being conscious when sleep
paralysis sets it it could have been an
evolutionary benefit so that our old
primate ancestors didn't fall out of the
tree when they had a little nap on a
branch but still given that in the US
alone 1.8 million people every year
visits the emergency room because they
fell out of bed evolution has quite a
long way to go in stage 2 your brain
sends out waves called sleep spindles
that we think how uses a sort of force
jammer to keep you calm and stop you
from thinking about the washing up or
that spreadsheet or where you hid the
bodies stage 3 is to transition from
light sleep into
deep sleep and stage 4 is where you get
a rush of delta waves and you are in
your deepest sleep stage 4 lasts about
30 minutes and is the best time to draw
on somebody's face finally you get stage
5 where REM sleep occurs and this is
when your body repairs itself shuts down
memories permanently and makes you feel
rested but the big question for today is
what kicks off the whole process what
happens to lead you to the fetus state
in stage 1 where it all begins
so there are two main factors that
controls sleepiness one is sleep
pressure something that increases the
longer that you've been awake for and is
created by the release of adenosine the
levels of adenosine rise whilst you're
awake and then you break it down whilst
you sleep the next factor is the light
we may now have 24 hours supermarkets
and Skype calls at 3:00 a.m. but we're
not designed for this we're supposed to
get up at sunrise and sleep it's sunset
just like the Teletubbies this is done
through melatonin which is released when
it's dark helping you to feel sleepy as
the Sun rises your body releases
cortisol which gets you open ready for
another day in your repetitive and
pointless existence ok so that all
sounds very well but what happens to
interrupt this complicated process
one day you're snoring like a pig in a
blanket and then BAM you're up at 4 a.m.
watching YouTube for the fifth night in
a row and although this video is both
entertaining and educational you're
welcome by the way you'd probably rather
be dreaming of a chocolate dinosaur
London riding a Tyrannosaurus Twix I'm
not waking up feeling like you've been
in a cage fight stress is probably the
main cause of why can't I effin sleep
because stress just throws all your
systems out of whack hormone levels go
all over the place heart rhythms change
it's a mess so you need to manage this
through tackling the cause of your
stress not saying that's easy but
there's plenty of professional supports
out there sorry I can't help you on that
front
then there's drugs both illegal and
legal caffeine for example works by
attaching to the adenosine receptors and
speeding up nerves
activity where adenosine will typically
slow it down so no TV for bedtime unless
it's one of those herb or monstrosities
if you want to call some salad in hot
water tea that's your prerogative I'll
be over here with my comforting babe
brew when insomnia strikes some people
turn to alcohol or marijuana but neither
is really a great option both can help
you to get to the early sleep stages
fairly quickly but they reduce the
amount of time in stage 5 REM sleep so
you won't wake up feeling refreshed and
your room will smell of fosters and
Domino's Pizza when it comes to
melatonin the biggest enemy is your
phone screen it's for that the biggest
obstacle to most people falling asleep
quickly today is technology the white
from a smartphone or laptop screen is
enough to trick your brain into thinking
it's still daylight so you won't produce
the necessary melatonin it can increase
the time it takes you to fall asleep by
over an hour it's important to give
yourself a good 30 minutes before bed
with no screens you should try that new
app where people take all the subtitles
from famous movies and print them out on
real sheets of paper except more
articulately written there's a lot of
misinformation out there about sleep
partly because there is so much we don't
understand so let's try to tackle a few
of the more common myths firstly the
obvious one counting sheep it's for that
this whole concept is derived from
actual shepherds they would worry about
their flocks going missing at night so
to make sure all was well they would go
out and count up the little and clouds
for you and I though with our worries
being decidedly non ovine counting sheep
is completely useless it actually
stimulates the active parts of your
brain you're much better off picturing a
relaxing scene like a beach or waterfall
and sure that can include sheep if you
like just make sure nobody else is in
attendance please exercise is very
important to keep you healthy and a good
active day will help you to nod off
quicker but if you're Restless doing
some sit-up
is only going to make things worse since
it will increase the adrenaline and more
importantly raise your core temperature
heat equilibrium is important for sleep
and you should be aiming to keep your
extremities warm with socks etc but your
core cool which is easy if you have a
frosty heart and finally we're often
told that you can train yourself to need
less sleep well you can't you can learn
to put up with it and maybe control your
mood a bit better but the fact is we
each have a typical sleep requirement
which differs from person to person
often 7 to 8 hours and with any less
than that we won't be running at our
optimum concentration will drop
significantly your temper will be
shorter and you'll find Janis in human
resources that extra bit annoying sure
she's irritating on a good day
but without a good sleep she's like
listening to Paris Hilton reading Fifty
Shades of Grey over a severely bad Skype
connection but no matter how much sleep
you manage to get each night the best
way to wake up feeling refreshed is to
avoid waking up during deep sleep doing
so will make you feel groggy and sleepy
for hours afterwards wake up during
light sleep and you'll feel awake and
refreshed but it's not just down to look
you can actually plan to wake up during
light sleep every morning it takes your
brain 90 minutes to go through one full
sleep cycle so try to always set your
alarm in 19 minute intervals giving you
the best chance of waking up during a
light sleep phase so you could set your
alarm for 6 hours after you go to bed or
seven and a half hours or nine hours all
are divisible by 90 minutes just make
sure you factor in the average of 14
minutes it takes for a person to fall
asleep so I hope this has helped some of
you insomniac sout there although I'm
not sure it was too smart of me to tell
my entire audience to stop staring at
screens no stirring after midnight then
deal and for those of you who do sleep
like a baby I hope you have someone to
change you in the middle of
night because you really should have
grown out of that bite now thanks for
the view subscribe for more 42